cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north bay
m pour accéder à une grosse promo et un
mois gratuit sur le plan de deux ans
allez sur north vbn point org
slash cyrus north ou bien utiliser le
code promo cyrus torse
plus d'informations à la voir la vidéo
je ne suis pas méchant personne n'est
méchant c'est fort désir femmes c'est
fort et c'est a priori faux on a tous
été victimes de méchanceté on connaît
tous quelqu'un qui est méchant c'est
même essentiel les méchants une bonne
histoire
c'est une histoire avec un bon méchant
on peut penser au plus grand méchant du
cinéma par exemple parc vador sauront
hannibal lecter le joker au passage que
vous écouter des podcasts
on a fait un épisode qui s'appelle le
meilleur méchant de cinéma avec jb de
thèse forme de clics et au rien prévost
je vous mets rien d'inscription où on
parle de ce méchant là justement je
crois que c'était il ya deux ans voilà
ça c'est du beau méchant quoi est
d'ailleurs l'expression beau méchant
elle est intéressante parce qu'on voit
pas comment un méchant pour être beau et
pourtant vous comprenez très bien ce que
je veux dire c'est méchant que j'ai
cités on pourra en parler longtemps et
ils ont quelque chose qui fait que ce ne
sont pas que de simples méchant dark
vador par exemple c'est pas un simple
méchant c'est un homme brisé
parce qu'il a perdu la femme qu'il
aimait et ses enfants en plus de la
pression incommensurable d'être
potentiellement un élus sauront ça un
être qui souhaitaient unifier la terre
du milieu sous un seul et même pouvoir
supérieur aux autres
le sien hannibal lecter c'est un
psychiatre extrêmement intelligent avec
un sens de l'esthétisme poussé au max
mais surtout un très jeune orphelin qui
a vu sa petite soeur se faire manger
sous ses yeux et le joker bassin malade
mental est ce qu'un malade mental peut
être réellement considéré comme un
méchant
chacun des personnages mériterait une
vidéo en entier on pourrait nuancer
mon propos sur plein d'aspects mais ça
change pas vraiment là où je veux en
venir pourquoi ils sont méchants
pourquoi on les appelle méchant il y as
philosophe qui s'appelle vladimir
jankélévitch donc il est mort le siècle
dernier en 85 à paris donc vraiment
c'était y'a pas longtemps
c'est tellement ya pas longtemps que
pour l'anecdote je connais des gens dont
le prof c'était jankélévitch je trouve
ça fou
eh bien il a dit la chose suivante est
plutôt que de le lire on va laisser
s'exprimer
lorsqu'on a épuisé toutes les
explications du comportement de
quelqu'un et que on voit que c'était que
ce comportement ne s'explique ni par
l'absence de lucidité il est au
contraire parfaitement lucide ni par
l'hérédité son hérédité est intact ni
par sa santé sa santé très bonne ni par
ses nerfs il n'a jamais été soigné pour
ses nerfs il souffre d'aucune affection
pathologique ligne outre ni par quoi que
ce soit d'autre
n'est ce pas aimé ce comportement ne
peut s'expliquer que par la méchanceté
la méchanceté est une limite de spa au
centre phénoménologique du mot est à
dire qu'elle n'est pas palpable
rien dans la méchanceté n'est positive
moi mais j'aurais pour tout cet homme
est méchant donc pour jankélévitch la
méchanceté c'est ce qu'on dit quand tu
sais plus quoi dire en fait c'est une
limite
- quand mes proches me traite de méchant
c'est parce qu'ils savent que je suis
pas stupide
ils savent que je suis pas névrosé à ce
point ils savent que voilà il ya pas de
raison particulière et donc en fait il
reste que ce à quoi je suis méchant ça
devient la seule explication alors qu'en
fait je fais un acte de méchanceté c'est
quelque chose qu'on a tous fait ou qu'on
fera tous mais c'est pas pour autant que
je suis méchant les méchants de cinéma
on les appelle méchant parce que c'est
plus simple en fait on n'a pas toujours
toutes les explications aux soit en nous
les donne pas à soi c'est compliqué
d'aller chercher soi il faut vraiment
analyser le personnage ou les appels
méchants les appeler méchant en fait
c'est la dernière analyse c'est un petit
peu comme un renoncement c'est un aveu
de faiblesse de la pensée alors
évidemment tout le monde ne pense pas
comme ça moi je pense comme ça et c'est
la thèse que j'ai envie de défendre dans
cette vidéo
et heureusement je suis pas le seul à le
penser
j'ai de bon philosophe avec moi à
commencer par le papa le papa de la
philosophie le bon socrates
socrates dit une phrase nul n'est
méchant volontairement se dire qu'il ya
d'un côté le mal et le côté la volonté
la volonté ne peut pas souhaiter le mal
donc si on souhaite quelque chose qui
est mal c'est qu'on se trompe
c'est qu'on souhaite mal pour socrate
on veut toujours ce qu'on pense être
bien et donc personne ne veut le mal
pour quiconque que ce soit pour les
autres ou surtout pour soi même si on
fait le mal c'est à cause de la pierre
des choses chez socrate l'ignorance le
pire des maux emmaüs c'est l'ignorance
et la pire ignorance
c'est l'ignorance d'être ignorants ça
c'est la thèse socratique mais c'est
quand même compliqué de se dire que les
pierres atrocités de l'humanité elle été
commise par ignorance ça peut pas être
une simple question d'ignorance laquelle
de la méchanceté là dedans
et pourtant on l'a vu ensemble dans la
vidéo sur la solitude
rappelez vous un extrait hannah arendt
aussi à souligner l'importance de la
solitude
non pas pour soi mais pour la société en
1961 elle est commissionné par le new
yorker pour couvrir le procès d'adolphe
iceman un officier ss qui a pris pas à
l'orchestration de l'holocauste est en
fait à se demander comment c'était
possible de faire quelque chose d'aussi
monstrueux et elle se disait il ya que
des psychopathes cinglé pour prendre
part à la choix possibles et en fait
elle a été surprise de voir que même si
ces actions était monstrueuse rischmann
la personne l'individu était au final
assez ordinaire quoi inquiéter qui était
pas démoniaque donc l'humain on n'est
pas tombé on n'est pas des animaux en as
raison même temps n'est pas diabolique
alors d'où vient cette méchanceté les
amis pour continuer à défendre ma thèse
j'en ai aucun autre pokémon peut-être
l'un des meilleurs quand séquentielle
emma d'autres
toi tu es tranche chalus face les
manuels et mon prénom
les corses le jeu tu assassines alors
j'ai réalisé que j'ai fait ça mais ça se
trouve je serais pas du tout dans le
rythme de la chanson voilà donc si
jamais vous me voyez faire ça sur un
rythme totalement inapproprié je suis
désolé pour quand
si on met les problèmes mentaux de côté
si on veut pousser notre volonté à
suivre la loi morale il faut qu'on se
rende indépendant de toutes nos
inclination naturelle qui nous pousse à
satisfaire nos désirs où nos intérêts et
notamment l'amour de soi quand il ya une
question de moralité qui se joue il va y
avoir une balance avec d'un côté un
mobile purement morale est un mobile
sensible de l'ordre de nos sens et pour
lui les êtres humains ont tendance à
privilégier les exigences de l'amour de
soi à celle de l'amour éviter c'est ce
qu'il appelle le penchant au mal donc en
gros
l'humain préfère simplement ce qui le
rend heureux parce que c'est de ça dont
on parle à ce qui le rend moral c'est
pour ça que quand à cette phrase qui
résume tous à ce que la jouissance de la
vie est une chose la moralité en est une
autre
donc ça signifie pas que la volonté va
être méchante ou mauvaise mais plutôt
qu'elle aura tendance à sacrifier
l'exigence morale par rapport à la
sensibilité donc pour quand
ce pas une question tu est diabolique
c'est une question d'être humain c'est
affreusement simple cette idée de vidéos
elle m'est venue en jouant à de la star
us de en vrai ça c'est une idée que
j'avais déjà eu mais elle est elle a
refait surface
à ce moment là quand j'ai fini le jeu et
a pas si longtemps de la sauce c'est
vraiment la série de jeux ma série de
jeux préférés en fait nous emmener dans
un monde post apocalyptique
vraiment c'est une sorte de koh vide qui
a très très mal tourner bien pire que ce
qu'on a là vous explorer ce monde là et
vous rencontrez d'autres factions
humaine qui essaient de survivre des
zombies bref ce genre de choses dans ce
deuxième opus lienne particularité alors
attention je vous mettrais un time code
parce que je vais spoiler et donc si
vous est arrivé à la fin du spoiler par
exemple vous êtes en train de jouer à
deux
2 ou que vous comptez jouer très
prochainement voilà sauter le spoiler je
m'en a time code ici dans ce deuxième
opus on commence par une scène très dur
il ya le camp adverse qui nous kidnappe
et qui commet un truc impardonnable en
parlant de détails parce que même si
vous êtes prête spoilers sur un que je
fasse gratos mais vraiment c'était une
scène insoutenable à regarder après
retouche du coup on va vouloir se venger
sauf qu'à un moment on nous fait jouer
l'antagoniste on va donc comprendre ses
motivations et comprendre que ce qu'on
pensait méchant ne le sont pas vraiment
en fait
on les pensait le méchant parce qu'on
n'avait pas les infos on ne pouvait pas
comprendre leur souffrance est en fait
un pur moment dans le jeu on se dit
nathan mais c'est moi le méchant en fait
c'est pas bien à ce que je en train de
faire et donc le jeu joue de ouf sont
notre perception entre le bien et le mal
qui est le gentil qui est le méchant et
ça change et c'est fou fans spoil tout
ça pour dire que quelqu'un de méchant
c'est quelqu'un qui souffre il ya le
fabuleux géraud de la chaîne doc gérault
qui parle de mécanique de game design
hyper intéressant il dissèque des jeux
vidéo puisque lui-même il en fait et
donc il nous explique comment ça marche
et c'est donc j'avais parlé avec lui de
la saveur et avait quelque chose à
rajouter sur ce thème là il m'a envoyé
une petite vidéo je vous montre juste
son point de vue que je trouve hyper
intéressant quand tu joues à the last
hope us de on en discutait un petit peu
tous les deux et il y avait un truc
intéressant qui revenait par rapport à
ce que tu retenait du jeu le fait qu'ils
aient pas vraiment un camp qui pensent
faire le mal en massacrant tout le monde
ce truc qui m'intéresse c'est qu'il ya
une vraie différence entre le regard du
joueur sur ses propres actions et le
regard du spectateur sur ces mêmes
actions en fait quand on est en train de
jouer à un jeu vidéo on perçoit tout
comme une information d'intensité plus
ou moins fortes et qui va nous aider à
savoir si ce qu'on a fait et réussi ou
non et qui va aussi nous aider à prendre
des décisions sur ce qu'on va faire
ensuite et dans the last of the c'est
exactement pareil en tant que joueur je
vois pas un mec qui explose de manière
horrible sur ma grenade avec ses membres
qui volent partout etc
et même si je sais que le gars va être
déchiquetés je lance pas cette grenade
par cruauté
je vois plutôt un visuel vif et intense
qui me dit que j'ai réussi mon coup et
que je peux passer au problème suivant
j'ai gorge pas non plus un mec par
surprise avec un plaisir sadique mais je
kiffe parce que c'est une opportunité de
jeu réussit et qui va par exemple me
permettre de
continuez à choper d'autres gars par
surprise et ne pas dépenser des
ressources rares comme des munitions
en gros c'est un petit peu de
l'optimisation d'ailleurs quand j'ai
fait le jeu une première fois bien sûr
j'ai trouvé sa violente dans sa
représentation mais pas tellement dans
les parties où je jouais qui elle était
plutôt satisfaisante alors qu'en
regardant ensuite des gens et jouer sur
youtube
j'ai trouvé que la mise en scène les
exécutions les tactiques de jeu tout
était hyper cruel et hyper violent
ces deux regards différents deux façons
de voir les choses merci beaucoup géraud
pour ce point de vue qui est hyper
intéressant vous invite à le suivre
c'est vraiment du taf de qualité et ça
n'a rien à voir mais depuis qu'il a fait
de l'escaladé
il a pris des épaules geroge teulet déjà
dit je te le redis en vidéo devant tout
le monde mais qui tue wôrô wôrô alors
voilà il ya des actes de méchanceté
c'est vrai mais est ce que pour autant
il ya des méchants est ce que ce n'est
pas que des aveux de faiblesse
est ce que ce n'est pas que des
renoncements est ce que ce n'est pas que
du manque de compréhension de la psyché
de l'autre et de son histoire de son
point de vue est-ce que parfois l'humain
choisi le mal pour le mal ou bien tout
simplement l'humain ne choisit pas le
bien pour d'autres raisons
vous connaissez mon point de vue sur ces
questions à la manne alors je me permets
qu'à une petite précision sur la
responsabilité parce que c'est important
j'ai pas envie qu'on me dise mais s'il
n'ya pas de méchants dans ce cas là
pourquoi les condamnés et c'est rien a
condamné non ce cas là c'est les
pardonner c'est c'est c'est dire que
voilà tout ça peut être admis et que y'a
pas finalement ils sont pas responsables
de ça puisqu'ils sont pas méchants est
ce que tout ça ça déresponsabilise la
méchanceté
non on est toujours tenu responsable de
nos actions quel qu'en soit le motif
en fait qu'on ait choisi le mal pour le
mal ou bien qu'on n'ait pas choisi le
bien pour d'autres choses comme dirait
quand pour l'amour de soi c'est un motif
qui aboutit à une action
cette action on en est quoi qu'il arrive
responsable c'est pas quelque chose qui
change et les actes de méchanceté
doivent être condamnés le méchant par
contre lui il n'existe pas et d'ailleurs
il est temps que vous parle d' un
dernier truc
qu'est ce que vous faites là quoi il est
4 heures 47 du matin est en train
d'écrire mon script et tout qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous faites là âge
c'est pourquoi vous êtes là vous êtes là
pour que je vous parle de normes bpl
messi côté je suis une tumeur je dois
vous parler d'enveloppés haine non
européennes c'est un service que
j'utilise depuis un an maintenant je
crois un vpn c'est un peu une chope
private network donc un réseau privé
virtuel
je vous la fait courte mais en gros ça
permet de vous protéger quand vous allez
sur internet notamment lorsque vous
allez sur des connexions public
genre je sais pas moi au mcdo par
exemple et que vous aller sur des sites
qui sont pas https bon j'avoue que moi
pour être serein je l'acte il wade que
j'utilise des wifi d'aéroports de deux
restaurants d'hôtels ce genre de choses
mais c'est pas ça la plus grosse
utilisation que j'en fais vu que c'est
un réseau en fait privé virtuel vous
pouvez faire croire que vous connecter
de n'importe où dans le monde
donc ça c'est très utile par exemple si
vous la regardez le catalogue netflix
aux états unis mais j'avoue c'est pas
pour ça j'utilise moi j'avoue je dis
surtout pour utiliser certains sites
lorsque j'écris mes vidéos voilà quand
je fais des recherches et parfois c'est
des sites qui ne sont pas accessibles du
lieu où je suis j'ai pas envie d'entrer
en détail mais ça m'est très utile
alors c'est sûr des stops mais c'est
aussi sur mobile est donc là admettons
jor-el me connecter en france bîmes
quick connect et c'est super ha ben je
peux aussi par exemple choisir de me
connecter depuis les etats unis
hop vous avez une garantie 30 jours
satisfait ou remboursé
donc voilà sur le testing ce truc
allez-y et d'ailleurs ça peut être aussi
utile et si vous voyagez dans certains
pays qui bloquent les accès à
l'extérieur et un service client m'a
pierce 24 7 jours sur 7
en français on apprécie et vous pouvez
avoir jusque 6 appareils connectés
simultanément sur le même compte
moi j'ai mon téléphone j'ai mon ipad
j'ai mon ordi c'est déjà bien assez
vous avez une énorme promo sur le plan
de deux ans et un mois gratos aux
patients européennes pointent comme
slash cyrus north et je les remercie
énormément d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo sur la méchanceté et de genre de
vidéos ou c'est pas évident trouver un
sponsor et ils ont accepté
merci à vous merci à toutes et à tous de
regarder cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle
vous
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à lâcher un
petit like et si vous faites pas c'est
pas grave je sais que c'est pas par
méchanceté
suivez moi sur un stage fédé story hors
du commun love peace ciao